is it too late to start YouTube in
2024 competition is a real thing but the
demand for good content on YouTube is
really higher than ever before over the
next 3 to 4 years the Creator economy is
going to double and be a half a trillion
dollar industry it's just getting
started and actually it's maybe one of
the best times to
start in this episode we're going to
answer the question is it too late to
start YouTube in 2024 and we're going to
talk about the pros and cons of starting
on YouTube right now I'm sitting here
with Sean Kell who's been doing YouTube
for 17 years has three silver play
buttons and a gold play button and has
built an entire 30 person company based
on YouTube so Sean I think you are well
qualified to answer the question is it
too late to start YouTube in 2024 well
short answer is it's not too late but I
don't expect anybody listening to this
to just take that short answer so if we
unpack that from a couple ways uh um
I've got some stats to share and then a
list of Pros a list of cons so let's
actually start with the stats going into
2024 YouTube now has 2.7 billion monthly
active users that's a crazy number
52% of Internet users period log into
YouTube at least once a month so really
I think one of the mindsets and
questions to ask is supply and demand
how much Supply how much demand of
content is there on YouTube and so so
competition is a real thing we'll get to
that later in the cons but the cool the
good news is that YouTube the demand for
good content on YouTube is really higher
than ever before and it continues to
increase because it increases at the
rate of new movies new shows new
marketing tactics new things in the real
estate environment new hobbies new side
hustles like there's just all there's
always new things people are interested
in and that's a lot of people one other
thing to know is that ask yourself who's
the largest YouTube Channel period a lot
of people's answer is Mr Beast for a
singular channel uh and an individual
although he's a team now he's up you
know 200 million close to that maybe a
little higher um that's pretty big it's
not the biggest you also have like E
Series that's kind of an Indian Channel
but I think maybe Coco melon is the
biggest and I I'm a pretty big Coco
melon fan these days blippy Coco melon
because I got a three-year-old um and so
when I think about okay if the largest
channel on YouTube is let's just call it
250 million subscribers that is actually
still just a drop in the bucket compared
to 2.7 billion people that are watching
YouTube monthly and logging in okay and
so what does that mean it also means
that as big as you think when you think
like everybody must watch this person oh
my favorite YouTuber that's got millions
of subscribers everybody knows about
them no they don't because there's so
many diverse people so when I do think
about the opportunity not everybody
wants to watch CoCo melon or Mr Beast
not not everybody likes this content
some people want to learn they want to
be educated they're into really Indie
type of music they're into Indie gaming
all kinds of different niches so I just
think it's like when you it's hard to
wrap our mind around the billion number
2.7 billion people it's a lot of people
to reach and then the question is just
like okay so how do I carve out my small
piece of that pie how can I even one of
the things we teach is how to make big
money with a small audience you know how
to really identify your Niche so that's
thing one I think some stats to know is
that YouTube is um available in over 80
native languages so there's like and
available in over a 100 countries I
believe so and maybe it's all of them
but I but I'm I'm kind of messing with
the stat there but the 80 languages
thing is like there's the YouTube Mexico
channel for example which is different
than youtube.com and the US and all of
that to say is that the international
opportunity is real I spoke at VidCon
2023 the last one and one of the biggest
things on the industry floor was talking
about just the international consumption
the international distribution so if you
want to start a channel in English great
but if you want to start a channel in a
different country or a different
language that opportunity is massive in
2024 as well then you also think about
tube filter has a old stat they haven't
updated this one but that over 200
million people have earned money in the
Creator economy so do we need to learn
some skills for sure do we need to learn
how to make good videos and hack the
algorithm and all of that stuff yeah but
maybe a better way to articulate the
amount of money to be made not that
that's the only metric of success should
can you start a YouTube channel as a
hobby and have fun in 2024 of course but
can you start a profitable Channel yes
and it was Yahoo finance that revealed
that the Creator economy and Creator
economy
businesses are the fastest growing small
business type right now so this is
exciting because you could in 2024 what
are you trying to achieve do you want to
open up a coffee shop do you want to
open up a flower shop do you want to
rent some commercial space do you want
to be a franchiser a franchisee of a
Subway or these different things you
could do or do you want to start a
Creator business well if you're
listening to this video podcast then
you're you're thinking about getting
into YouTube and a quick tip there is I
think one of the most powerful ways you
can start YouTube is with a business
mindset not many start they think oh
it's going to be a side hustle it's
going to be a hobby
fine but Yahoo finance said this is the
fastest growing business type and I
found that by shifting your mindset from
kind of like oh I'm just dabbling in a
hobby to I want to dominate this as a
business forces you to think a little
bit different okay what skills do I need
how how could I approach this
strategically how could I approach this
more intentionally and so this is the
fastest growing small business type and
that is continuing into
2024 that speaks to to the opportunity
of starting and growing but also the
opportunity of making money but probably
the most significant recent youTube stat
That Shook Me To The Core was Goldman
Sachs research
revealing that over the next 3 to four
years the Creator economy is going to
double and be a half a trillion dollar
industry so let let's unpack that first
of all right now they revealed and this
is Wall Street
people that are smarter than me smarter
than us here we are sitting in Las Vegas
in our video podcast studio uh you're
pretty brilliant I I'm glad to be
getting to be here with you but I mean
ultimately you know we're sitting here
these are analyst Financial analysts
looking at Big Data looking at numbers
looking at all this different stuff so
they have evaluated that the crater
economy currently is evaluated at $250
billion it's kind of one way of looking
at how much money is in the system you
know if you appli this to a different
industry they might might say how much
how much money is in restaurants Topline
like how much money is in um network
marketing it's this big of an industry
So currently the Creator economy is a
$250 billion industry that's a massive
number and if you had just a tiny piece
of that the practicality of earning an
extra 10 grand a year or $555,000 a year
or whatever is is more practical than
people realize but okay it's 250 right
now and what Goldman Sachs research is
looking at based on all economic factors
and things we're look in this
environment I mean people sometimes we
get Doom and Gloom oh is it a recession
what's going to happen next and of
course different things can happen but
they look at the market they look at
what's happening they look at the Trends
they say okay that's going to double in
the next four
years the reason this is so insane is
because as you mentioned I've been on
YouTube 17 years YouTube's only existed
for I think 19 2005 so you go 200 5 to
2014 that's 19 years I started my first
channel for uh my local church in a
small town an hour north of Seattle
called Maryville Washington it was a
terrible Channel I mean it was fine
because it was for a church but the in
these days you had a 15minute upload
limit no custom thumbnails we were doing
everything wrong our technology was
inferior all this different stuff but I
just have had the privilege of being in
the game a long time personally growing
channels helping others grow if I'm
understanding Goldman Sachs research
correctly they're saying this I've
watched the whole thing from start to
now grow for the last 19 years from 200
2005 and and when did the creator
economy start well it started to be fair
it's not just YouTube this would be the
other social platforms when did it start
it started whenever the first platform
probably YouTube you had YouTube
Facebook came a little bit later now X
then eventually Instagram those are kind
of being of course the big ones YouTube
by far and Facebook I think are you know
maybe the biggest terms of of Money
YouTube pays the most as far as craters
okay great so it has taken from 2005
until
20124 that long for the crater economy
to become worth $250 billion for that
much money to be in the system and it's
crazy now when we think about that we
think about our own experience we've
generated millions of dollars in our
company from 21 different income streams
great okay but what about people
listening to this and other people and
they've probably watched YouTubers get
famous that are entertaining
education YouTubers doing doing DIY and
Etsy making money we get to see our
students results so we see behind the
scenes and see people making a couple
Grand a month a few hundred dollars a
month from affiliate marketing we see
how much money is in the system of
e-commerce and affiliate marketing just
you make a video and recommend jeans or
fashion or supplements or whatever and
how much money is there okay so it's
taking 19 years for this whole thing to
be valued at $250 billion and Goldman
Sachs research says all that's happened
in the last 19 years is doubling in the
next four I that's the point I'm trying
to get across massive acceleration is it
too late it's just getting started and
actually it's maybe one of the best
times to start if you're looking to get
your first thousand subscribers or make
your first $11,000 on YouTube then join
our free YouTube challenge that many
other small creators have joined and
seen tons of success during this free
challenge Sean is going to share some of
the best strategies for growing to your
first 1,000 sub subscribers on YouTube
as well as making your first $11,000
just go to tube1 challenge.com or check
the link down in the description now I
would encourage listeners to to listen
until the end because there's there's no
question there's Giants to slay this is
not going to be an easy Endeavor but if
you have the right skills and develop
those and the right strategies great but
I can't even comprehend that level of
acceleration because as much energy and
data that I can transferer through this
podcast of what it's been like for me to
be on the ride of the last 17 years of
YouTube see what's happened see the
life's Chang see the stories see peers
Friends interview over 300 400 different
entrepreneurs and video influencers and
creators that are making content it goes
on and on it's it's already mind-blowing
what's happened up into this point to
say it's going to double and even if
it's it's like half of that the next one
two 3 four years are going to be insane
so I think about it like positioning
yourself to write a wave positioning
yourself now to capitalize to cash in on
what's Happening and of course it's not
just about the money our value is you
need money for the mission it's really
about impact it's about people but you
need money to sustain it so how do I
make a profitable YouTube channel how do
I go full-time in the creater economy
how do I work from home I think the data
the numbers not opinions support that
getting into this game right now is the
right time to start and what would you
say are the pros and the cons to getting
started now yeah so uh I got a couple
that are written down here so I think uh
five pros and five cons number one on
some of the pros first um you do have
audience reach we already hit it but
YouTube is a vast Global platform that
will allow you to reach people worldwide
2.7 billion monthly active users and
continuing to grow number two I think is
also uh creative expression you know we
do have an episode we can link up in the
show notes that maybe goes through 15 or
or or so reasons and so you could say
Reach people you could say um make money
but you could also say like history and
Legacy like you and creative expression
history and Legacy documenting your
family like documenting memories
documenting your transformation
transferring your knowledge into videos
so that God forbid you you know as a
father I think about this I think about
what if I was to get sick or what if
something awful would happen this is why
I would get life insurance is my wife
set up is my family set up but then I
also think man I want to watch my kids
grow up my one-year-old and my
three-year-old but if I didn't one of
the things that gives me peace is that I
actually could father my kids in some
Digital Way by the videos I have on
YouTube like there's so much different
content it's even why now I want to
share more vision and more values
because again if worst case scenario my
life's cut short my son's could learn so
much from their dad could pick up so
many different things because of putting
videos then I think about creative
expression just becoming a Creator not
just a consumer there's stats that
reveal there are negative um Health
aspects mental health aspects to social
media and we have to like comparison
like you know sometimes overc
consumption but here's also what's Wild
Adobe did a study there's also stats
that reveal positive mental health Corel
relation to being a Creator creative
expression when we make something when
you shoot edit upload post on the just
the process itself is rewarding and the
process itself is transformational you
become a different person I believe in a
positive way it challenges you it
stretches you sure you get uncomfortable
but that's where growth is there's also
the potential to make uh revenue and
we've got episodes on all the different
ways of making money but there's a real
Financial opportunity and in 2024 those
unities just continue to expand there's
never been more YouTube just added
shopping there's shopping integration
their own kind of Affiliates that's
right through the platform you've got
all their different ways of making money
from Super chats to ad Revenue but then
you got brand deals sponsorships
packaging your own uh products and
programs um and a topic for another day
merchandise sales um skill development
creating content enhan to skills like
video editing storytelling and digital
marketing and I would say that our
stated mission is to have people get
direct success on YouTube like we want
to help them get results on YouTube but
here's one of the things that gives me
great confidence about what we do if you
just embark on this journey and you
start to develop skills it's kind of
like a rising tide lifts All Ships you
just begin to learn things like you you
understand marketing more content more
attention more it'll make you a better
employee it'll make you a better um
Communicator it just kind of forces you
to level up you develop skills and yes
skills directly related to YouTube but
it'll influence other areas of your life
and other practical areas of business
being a small business owner if you are
one all kinds of things Community
Building relationships I mean one reason
why too to start a YouTube channel no
joke maybe you'll find your spouse like
maybe maybe you'll find a best friend I
have actually people who I would say are
my best friends one is Alejandro Reyes
we met because of YouTube and so it's
wild now Alejandro Sarah there their
daughters the intimate conversations the
memories we've made together the things
that have happened that's cuz I started
a YouTube channel that is crazy like
he's such a homie he's such a brother
you know like and and the community you
could build the life set you could
change the connections that could be
made so I definitely would encourage um
you know we always link up great show
notes but there are even more Pros than
that but that's five Pros what are some
cons and we can unpack these and I think
we're doing a two-part episode here so
if if people are new make sure to
subscribe uh wherever listen or watch
and in part two we'll get really
tactical and I want to break down a case
study of a theoretical Channel I would
start and exactly how I could do it and
the Nuance is there so anyways look for
part two of the episode but um some cons
okay High competition for sure and I do
believe the demand for good content is
still outpacing Supply as many videos as
there are I never have enough I watch
YouTube every day and if you're
listening to this you might not when we
go go home and um or at the end of a day
work from home and go downstairs I get
grab my Apple remote I open up YouTube
like YouTube is kind of the world I live
in and a lot of people are living in
that world it's you watch your favorite
video podcasters all this different
stuff okay great so there's demand but
there is competition and so with
millions of channels standing out and
getting a substantial following could be
challenging um and saying that I mean
man we could really Camp here but I
think the the footnotes could be like so
you got to ask yourself how can you
position yourself to be different how
can you play to your strengths minimize
your weaknesses how can you find a
unique angle in the market or how can
you just assess that maybe you're not
going to be the biggest but how big is
the Tam how big is the total addressable
Market here's what I mean we encourage
people to ask what's the largest YouTube
channel in the topic that you're
interested in starting a Channel about
for example we have a tech Channel
called think media
and I think about tech itself and I
think that maybe Marquez brownley MKBHD
might be the biggest Tech Channel and I
think he's at 15 million or 17 million
who knows fact check I don't know but
it's you know so you think about that
some people look at that they see as
competition I actually see that as
verification that the market is so big
that the opportunity for you to build an
a th000 3,000
7,500 P subscribe Channel around an
aspect of tech monetizing in a few ways
and maybe in the next 12 months building
up your monthly Revenue to a few hundred
a few thousand if you were just going
pure Creator from scratch that's that
that competition is sometimes kind of
overrated like now the flip side is you
you do want to assess what are the
different market dynamics meaning if you
were to start a channel what's the
biggest channel on underwater basket
weaving I don't even think there is one
you might be able to be a big fish in a
small town like a dedicated Channel and
under a big smish big fish in a small
pond that's something to think about so
again subscribe to the podcast and um we
will and look at our past history
there's a lot of tips for standing out
from high competition I think a second
one is it could be time consuming I
think that when you think about starting
a YouTube channel that sometimes we
don't think
through what is this what is this going
to take um we have a a teaching that we
have in um some of our paid courses that
we do that talks on the um the five hour
YouTube Work week and we get really
detailed and productivity kind of time
management and how you could do this so
it's good to know that you can have a
very successful YouTube channel and
consistent YouTube channel in five hours
or less a week but I think you still
need to budget that I mean one 100% of
us myself included could find five hours
if we were disciplined and thoughtful
and what could we move around but two
you still have to find the five hours
you actually got to commit so I think
starting is it too late to start no um
but starting is going to take some
things from you it's going to take time
it's going to take commitment it's going
to take it doesn't have to take 40 hours
a week you could do it as a side Hustle
but producing quality content
consistently requires an investment of
time and of effort and you want a budget
for that I think three is changes with
the algorithm um the algorithm there's a
lot of principles that remain the same
for the algorithm minutes matter most
watch time can you get people to click
on a video and keep them watching that's
the oversimplification but in in a
recent episode we did with ls how he was
talking about how and and I think across
the board we've seen this that in the
last six months a lot of people are like
My Views are down videos certain videos
the way that they used to perform aren't
performing the same way you could
definitely see like there's certain
algorithm things how is YouTube
prioritizing shorts how does it work
with long form how did the two work
together and and maybe another way to
put number three is the con would be
learning
curve
is learning how YouTube Works learning
the different skill sets
that uh are required to have success on
YouTube we're not here trying to make
this overly simple or say like this is
this is going to be easy there's
something about learning how to speak
and communicate learning how to edit
learning about how to capture all you
need is your smartphone and editing
could be simple but that's still a
learning curve learning how YouTube
works I think number four this is a big
one is is negative feedback um is is a
level of an emotional toll that could
hits you by being on YouTube just
different sometimes it's direct negative
feedback you get a comment that hurts
sometimes it's a little bit imagined but
kind of real oh man I'm like putting
myself out there like what are people
thinking about me and maybe somebody
says a negative comment but then you
kind of amplify it you're like is that
what everybody thinks my video got you
know 100 views and I got a three
positive comments but somebody said a
kind of a mean thing is are people just
watching me and judging me you just can
really get all in your feels all in your
head and so you're ultimately exposing
yourself to public scrutiny and negative
comments can be a downside and they can
be something that you do want to prepare
for we encourage you to have thick skin
but a soft heart we often quote
Aristotle who said if you know if you
want to avoid criticism just be nothing
say nothing and do nothing so to avoid
criticism on YouTube not starting a
channel on YouTube would be one way to
do it because that's you know it's not
an issue but more than anything I think
that's something to prepare care for to
develop mental toughness um to be
connected to a strong Community probably
digital for most um that's one the
people thing that people love about um
our like V Community is even just a
place where you can relate and process
and like yeah that was kind of mean but
it did kind of hurt but like yeah let's
push through it and and to have some
level of of encouragement happening
you'll probably discover that your
spouse your partner your friends and
anybody in your world that is not a
content creator they won't even get it
they can't relate and you'll feel pretty
lonely because they can't relate and
it's not they're not bad for that but
you know they also you're like that I
put a lot of work in that video and that
comment really hurt and your husband's
like what's the big deal and you're like
well I know it's not a big deal but like
it is I'm thinking about it you know so
I think um you know trying to put some
answers to these cons by thinking about
okay do you have a good Circle you know
can you put yourself in an environment
with people that can relate to just the
different things as you grow and then
another one could be like Revenue
inconsistency I think getting to the
point of monetization I think to prepare
yourself that in the beginning of any
Endeavor start a small business start a
side hustle start a YouTube channel the
amount of work you put in at the
beginning radically exceeds the amount
of Revenue you make at the beginning
often being zero at the beginning and
even for quite a long time for some they
can grow very quickly or make money in a
relatively short amount of time but
maybe it's 3 months or 6 months before
you get monetized or make some affiliate
income maybe it's a year are you willing
to put that work in I think the
important mindset to have is that right
there is you got a shift from a 9 to-5
mentality an employee mentality which
you're just used to like I went and
worked at my job you know for eight
hours and then I made 20 bucks an hour
and and I got time for money cool you
know I my background is in Waiting
tables I worked at Red Robin for 10
years from s to 27 I'm 40 now and so I'm
waiting table so I knew if I double
shift on a Saturday that I could go wait
tables at Red Robin serve people fries
serve people Burgers drink a rock star
or a monster to like push through the
whole day and usually walk away from1
$150 $200 in tips from that one day of
work a crazy day that was kind of the
revenue there depending on my sales and
how well it was tipped plus my arly and
then I would go home and side hustle on
YouTube and make zero and then
eventually I got my first uh paycheck
from the Amazon affiliate program and I
made
$212 Maybe by that time after I posted
200 videos so
economically the one person could look
at that and be like you're wasting your
time like what are you even doing this
is it's not worth your time and the
shortsighted mindset that would be true
but the longi the the the Long View
entrepreneurial mindset would say no no
no no I'm putting extra work and I'm
underpaid at the start so that as I
break through and once I break through
that I could be overpaid in the future
that is the difference between kind of
the employee mentality and the business
owner mentality because what do business
owners also know the average small
business is not profitable for 18 to 24
to 36 months are you willing to go a
year two years 3 years to get a project
off the ground again there's always
different unicorn kind of stories and we
have radical certain students that do
certain things but generally you want to
kind of Baseline your mind set to say am
I willing to really put the work in
again if you want to start in 2024 with
the intent of being successful I think
it's important to go in with the right
uh the right mind mindset and so Revenue
could be delayed but that's normal and
it's delayed in everything results in
working out are delayed too you have
like New Year's resolutions like man I
went to the gym for like two weeks I
don't have a six-pack yet like I can't
like bench 400 pounds yet well of course
so I think going into it man I'm going
to put the work work in and I I want to
learn new skills the cons are
overcomable but I think it is
approaching them with the cons High
performers actually perform best by not
being too overly optimistic we were
talking about in one of our team and
core values that uh there's like a quote
that says good leaders have endless
optimism about the future but they also
have like a brutal understand
understanding of reality they say what
are the facts what are the reality but
they look at reality with optimism so
we're not it's not being delusional or
even being overly optimistic but I do
think you have to have that optimism
that faith that fight to keep going by
being like these are some of the things
that I got to overcome and in doing so
what am I going to need to do to
overcome and of course that's what this
two-part series is about and uh that's
actually I mean we have a a web class
that people could watch we can link that
up uh in the description as well that'll
get into some real tactics because
that's our we want to help a million
Purpose Driven people create a full-time
living on YouTube and experience that
success without losing their soul which
let me put one other con in there one of
the cons could actually be success
you're not ready for and so that's a
topic for another day but sometimes you
know what if some people are thinking
can I start a YouTube channel and could
it be successful it's a great question
let's get you there but the question
nobody is asking is am I ready for
YouTube success am I actually am I ready
for some of the momentum that could come
am I ready for now some of the pressure
am I ready that wow a lot of money's
coming in but also there's some negative
feedback and I have to develop a new
mindset and skill set that's what of
course we want to help people with and
can I experience I'm moving from maybe a
more structured lower risk lifestyle
into a more uncomfortable higher risk
and you know when I was doing some
research we'll land the plane but that
Revenue inconsistency is interesting or
or there's not maybe just how long does
revenue take but also that Revenue
inconsistency being a Creator um it
doesn't come with Healthcare if you do
it full-time it doesn't come with the
401K unless you set it up yourself it
doesn't come with the stability of my
boss will pay me this salary or this
hourly wage pretty much no matter what
so long as I maintain my job there's
maybe higher revenue or there is in
certain months of the year lower at
other times there's certain Seasons so
there's the direct skill sets we help
people learn editing camera
confidence um you know how to get views
hacked algorithm all that stuff then
there's all this whole thing like how do
I manage my money how do I you know get
better at some of these things and so
there's pros there's cons but it's
definitely not too late and let me just
land the plane once we've landed the
plane we are taxing to the to the gate
right now um but I I would say and not
just my opinion I think it was Mr Beast
that said YouTube is the most generous
algorithm on the internet if you know
how the algorithm works and because it's
really shifted from subscribers actually
mattering less more to what people are
interested in if you learn the skill set
of title topic packaging you know
editing and and these things and and
stick around we we'll help you learn all
that brand new channels are growing
rapidly and so the it's not like okay
it's the halves and the Hales not if you
have subscribers then then you're good
good in fact this could be revealed that
some even older Channels with lots of
subscribers are struggling cuz they're
not pivoting and adapting to how YouTube
is working now flip side it makes me
think of Like Larry Chung one of our
students in the recent like last couple
years like this current ERA of YouTube
again oh I I wish I would have started
10 years ago I wish I would have started
you know eight years ago I wish I
started whatever no start today uh he
started and in six months he grew 53,000
subscribers he got almost a million
views he's in personal finance which is
very competitive but it's huge because
everybody deals with money so back to
that thing like what about competition
how many other personal finance channels
are there probably a million but it's
possible 53,000 subscribers and he only
posted 14 videos so 0 to 53,000 now he's
got a silver play button one of our V
students um I think there there not just
I think there is a major opportunity to
start a brand new channel from from
scratch and grow especially when you
understand growth principles and you
know we'll talk about that in the next
episode and on the web class and things
like that and so I think the a age-old
quote when's the best time to plant a
tree 10 years ago when's the second best
time to plant a tree today when's the
best time to you know start a business
five 10 years ago when's the second best
time today when's the best time to chase
your dreams you've been waiting you've
been on the sidelines five or 10 years
ago would have been a good time to chase
your dreams but you've been waiting well
then get started today and uh all my
friends and peers that also you know
YouTube experts this question gets asked
every single year we probably answer it
every single year and and we want to
answer it with full transparency and
integrity and it's not too late to start
that's just a fact so punch fear in the
face punch perfectionism in the face and
press record yes it's absolutely not too
late to start and if you want the
strategies for um the real tactics for
growing a YouTube channel in 2024 make
sure you're subscribed to this channel
because in the next episode Sean's going
to be breaking down an actual case study
of what he would be doing um to grow a
YouTube channel in 2024 starting now and
so that's going to be heavy tactical
giving you those next steps that you
need in order to really win in 2024 so
um we'll see you in that next episode
make sure that you subscribe and we'll
see you there